china is going green
that is the message president xi jinping
sent out on state television if true it
would certainly help cool the planet
and keep climate change in check china
is before by far the world's biggest
polluter currently responsible for 27
percent of greenhouse gas emissions to
compare this the united states emits 11
while india and the countries of the
european union each emit just over six
percent of global greenhouse gases china
is of course has the world's largest
population so its per capita pollution
comes out lower than the united states
but those numbers have been rising as
well
with devastating effects for the country
dense smog regularly covers shanghai and
other big cities causing tens of
thousands of deaths every year now
president xi says it's now time to
change course as he visited the
country's largest man-made
forest
saihanba forest stretches much further
than the eye can see
covering 20 000 square kilometers it is
the world's largest man-made forest and
home to more than a thousand species of
plants and hundreds of species of
mammals birds fish and insects
the area used to be a barren desert
known for sandstorms work on saihanba
started in 1962 when tree planters first
moved in to cultivate the grounds
work that continued for decades
chinese president xi jinping knows how
important the forest is
on state media he promised more projects
like it
china needs to promote this
spirit to better develop the country and
the green economy as well as ecological
civilization
improving the environment and protecting
it state television also showed she
visiting a fire prevention tower inside
saihanba and learning about the
monitoring systems installed there
as the world's biggest polluter china
has long been asked to change direction
g's current plan to reach net zero
emissions for the country by 2060.
all right for more let's bring in doris
fisher she holds the chair of china
business and economics at the university
of wurzburg welcome to dw now reaching
carbon neutrality by 2016 may be china's
goal but there's a long way to go
especially since over half the coal
plants under development globally are in
china why is the country still clinging
to coal
well the
energy policy of china needs to or
pursues two goals one is
getting green the other is to secure
energy secure i mean make energy secures
and have energy secure energy supply and
for that the coal is still important
those because china doesn't want to be
to be dependent on
energy imports and second because um
they are so there is so much abundance
of coal available uh that uh the the
coal is just the cheap energy source and
so a good provider of energy and it is
of course also important uh to securing
economic growth for china but approvals
for new coal power plants are declining
aren't they
they are and i mean the chinese
government is very much aware that they
have to change track in terms of the
energy supply and energy mix that is not
a recent decision actually or
the environmental policy started or the
stress on environmental policies started
as early as since the 2000s and in 2016
already the chinese government and under
xi jinping came up with a quite
far-reaching new set of energy policies
they have somehow accelerated the goal
so to speak or strengthen the goals uh
recently
but the idea is really to get um well to
to shift to an energy mix where the
renewables will provide first uh kind of
the energy is it all the energy that is
uh necessary for economic growth of the
additional energy and then eventually
also substitute fossil fuels now you
mentioned the somewhat two-tier
energy policy there in china the country
is investing more into green energy than
any other country why is that
well for a number of reasons one is as i
said energy security so then the
additional energy they knew they need
should come from renewables second they
also have the hope that uh green uh
energy technologies will contribute to
china's economic development um in terms
of well energy technology being part of
global competitiveness i mean we had
this
to talk about the green growth race
already as early as the 2010s or so
and uh finally also i mean climate
change mitigation is something that the
government wants to achieve not least
because the impact of climate change
will be heavier for china and then the
more obvious or short-term goal is also
to get rid of the the bad air i mean to
improve air quality because that's
something that people i mean the normal
people even if they are not very much
educated on climate change issues would
uh suffer from in the daily and
experience daily and therefore the
population also expects the government
to change this
finally when president xi declares china
will become carbon neutral by 2060
what are we to make of that figure that
is still quite uh far off
well he had has a two-step call and so
that is uh carbon peak by 2030 and that
is as i said pretty much in line with
energy policies that have been out there
before uh it's a bit more ambitious than
than this energy package so to speak or
policy package of 2016.
and the path from from from the carbon
peak to to to carbon neutrality is um
very demanding um but in general what we
have seen in the past is that china is
rather actually stating
unambitious goals so to speak so that um
it is clear that they can outperform the
self-defined goals maybe a bit different
from what we see in other countries
where we define ambitious goals
as a kind of a landmark in order to
achieve those goals at least come close
to these goals so to raise the
expectations and china usually that is a
tradition from the planning economy
goals are formulated rather modestly so
that you can later say hell we have
achieved those goals premately
prematurely doris fisher of the
university of wurzburg thank you for
talking to us
thank you